Fran Townsend is with us she was the see
she is our CBS News senior national
security analyst she was homeland
security and counterterrorism advisor
for president george w bush welcome Fran
what are investigators trying to find
out from the shooter well they want to
understand both his mental history we
know that there was this report from a
video blogger on YouTube back in
September identifying crews to the FBI
difficult when I say identifying he
identified the common he was interviewed
the video bloggers asked if he knew him
he said no he didn't know him this was
reported to YouTube and they took it
down but it points to a host of issues
John so for one we don't think when we
think of Homeland Security we think of
terrorism issues we think of natural
disasters we don't think of school
shootings and you know right now when
you think of this you know we've had
this is the 18th school shooting this
year last year this time we had seven
should we rethink homeland security
because it sure feels like terrorism to
me it hurts as badly it's just as
terrible do we need to rethink what
homeland security really means I think
that's exactly right Gail I mean imagine
for a moment if the shooter had been a
Muslim beautifully having a that's
exactly right and and how wrong does
that feel right and so we this ought to
be at the top of the list of homeland
security threats because we have an
obligation to protect our children and
we need to deal even though it's a
difficult political issue it's time for
people to put that aside and really say
we're gonna deal with it I'm also
interested in the assault rifle that he
used in air 15 which can cost about two
thousand dollars it's a lot for a 19
year old working at a dollar store but
also the ar-15 has been used in six of
the deadliest mass shootings in this
country
Aurora Newtown San Bernardino Las Vegas
the pole shooting inland Orlando
Sutherland Springs do we need to have
some changes at the ATF and others about
who can buy this type of weapon you know
look Nora you know better than anybody
there's been these debates in Washington
about putting these restrictions the NRA
says that's a slippery slope you begin
down that path people ought to remember
that this was the AR the assault rifle
was really intended for military use
right I think of that from
government is being a weapon used by our
the u.s. military overseas we understand
that law-enforcement people in uniform
have an absolute need for it but this is
a debate look we had an assault weapons
ban it expired and the politicians in
Washington don't seem to be willing to
continue to have that Denine teen
year-old who has been kicked out of
school be able to buy that gun no so the
one other issue I wanted to raise this
morning is the social media companies
look in this case YouTube to take that
comment down when it was identified to
them and just declare that comment
exactly what he what he said in there is
he said I'm going to be a professional
shooter right and so they took that down
but they need to do more right they need
to provide resources people who go
hunting on their networks YouTube
Facebook Instagram where they find this
stuff they they don't just take it down
they take it down and record to law
enforcement so we can try and prevent
these things before they happen no the
man who said it so it said he he showed
it to the FBI and that he was
interviewed but where did it go from
there did anybody follow up with this
with this Nicolas Cruz right well we
don't know and it's you don't know if
they actually were able to identify him
from you know Nicolas Cruz's a common
name could they identify him could they
find him and interview him did they
understand he had other social media
accounts that might have triggered even
more concerned okay
Thank You Fran thank